yo tom
is the bomb
on-screen kisses can lead to awards
intense connections and sometimes even
full-fledged romances
uh who was your first ever celebrity
crush
everyone shipped zendaya and tom holland
for so long and of course they exploded
the internet with this photo
but before they really got together they
dealt with everyone hoping they'd get
together which no doubt added a bit of a
difficult layer i kind of know what we
signed up for as for actually kissing in
performance
i think like the closer you are with
someone the weirdest the weirder it is
kind of like the backwards thing about
it luckily it seems off-screen is a lot
less weird i'm going to feel the same
way yeah
they met on set they played love
interests on screen they shared some
kisses that turned out to be pretty
great so they went official and can kiss
as much as they want whenever they want
familiar story
that's the charlie heaton and italia
dyer love story and it does wonders for
their chemistry on screen the actors are
quite private about their relationship
which makes sense since stranger things
fans essentially got to watch them fall
in love on screen already hey how did
you deal with it
all the attention
take a look at these kisses
can you say chemistry victoria pedretti
and dylan arnold certainly could since
after a season of playing unbelievably
charming love interests the you pair are
dating in real life as well while they
didn't get it on screen we're glad the
two get to have their happy ending off
screen things obviously turned out much
better for both of them
um
sometimes you've just got to rehearse a
kissing scene as much as needed right
love is tight it might be what chase
stokes and madeleine klein had in mind
when they started dating off screen as
well though the spark wasn't instant
after working together a bit the two
felt the chemistry
i definitely had some feelings everyone
recognized it even mtv with their best
kiss award i feel like there's so many
people that i want to thank um i'm kind
of panicking right now
since the two broke up we're not so sure
how they'll be feeling about on-screen
smooches if a third season of outer
banks comes
along um
those
feelings
were real they were young and rising to
worldwide fame it's very intimidating
going into that back in their twilight
days stuart and pattinson played coy but
stewart wouldn't lie about how she
really felt kissing pattinson all the
time
it's great i like it
of course she did they did date for a
long time but their chemistry read
together was definitely a solid start
and you know they were so passionate
like right then and we had to have rob
and then kristen and rob had to have
each other
so it's like it's not difficult like for
me as a man to be like oh yeah let me do
everything i can to like make you feel
it just works it just works yeah on
screen we only see the love between
rebecca and jack pearson and obviously
milo ventimiglia does as well and it's
deeper than just a physical you know the
two found such a connection and real
deep love for each other even though
it's not a romantic one it's not a bad
job it's pretty easy seems like a pretty
great gig
i'm telling you
that i love you it would be silly to
think a franchise called the kissing
booth wouldn't involve a lot of kissing
but in this case there was even more
smooching than we'd anticipate since
lead actors joey king and jacob allordy
were dating off screen as well
obviously all these on-screen makeout
sessions were a pretty good start king
recognized just how cute the aussie is
but the two kept it casual off the bat
until a month worth of filming kisses
later and the actors started the
beginning of their real-life romance
which unfortunately ended before they
filmed the second and third movies
by the time they wrapped everything we
have a feeling neither was enjoying
their kisses just as much
how
when ryan reynolds filmed green lantern
he was married but not to his co-star
and now wife blake lively who by the way
was dating gossip girl co-star penn
badgley at the time
lively and reynolds became very close
while filming and their relationship on
screen translates just how strong a
connection they had you know we really
like each other it took some time to
figure out they had a spark but no doubt
those movie kisses helped while it is a
romantic story the two of them never
fail to razz on each other went well for
him i i were no fireworks for me tom
holland probably agrees with zac efron
as far as kisses go yeah this might be
my favorite kiss well not that kiss
exactly holland's kisses with zendaya
you get what we're saying ephron
endlessly raved about zendaya and who
can blame him their emotional connection
and admiration for each other as artists
really helped make those sparks fly
i fell in love with my co-star
another case of love found through a
series kit harington and rose leslie had
an instant connection when they began
working together we really get on uh as
friends and we we hit it off very
quickly when we when we first met
harrington has admitted he was attracted
to his co-star and he very much enjoyed
getting to play her love interest and
get those kisses in especially as he was
realizing that he was falling in love
for real rose leslie was a pretty big
fan of practicing those on-screen kisses
off screen too
he made it very easy
dan and serena's make-outs on gossip
girl were pretty enjoyable experiences
for both actors
at least for a while
the chemistry was so electric that the
performers took their relationship off
screen making those on-screen kisses
that much better i'd say best i'll say
i'll say it was blake because we
actually had a relationship at the time
of course long term the shoot didn't
work out but they did continue to play
lovers on screen uh talk about awkward
badgeley wasn't really a big fan of the
kissing after that and then and then the
worst maybe blake after we broke up
these two were never meant to kiss and
yet and the director yelled out kiss and
we got thrown into it while it was an
unplanned moment it did lead to a whole
lot more off screen so definitely not a
bad way to start liam hemsworth and
miley cyrus really showed how to make
the most of a single kiss it was good
you know it was a good way of doing it
how did ryan gosling and rachel mcadams
develop their passionate connection on
screen you know you have love scenes in
their private time
that's not true
while what gosling said was a joke it
kind of wasn't
the chemistry with with rachel was
immediate they didn't start off on the
best foot professionally but working
together and getting ready to perform
award-winning kisses on screen still
brought on a mix of feelings i think i
was more nervous about it than she was
while it didn't work out their
relationship made for something pretty
special
just a feeling there just everything
sort of fit and everything worked after
filming the words together as lovers it
became very easy for the two to see each
other romantically
and they dove in full tilt she's
incredible to work with yeah i mean i
was always a fan of hers the on-screen
and off-screen kisses ended pretty
quickly just a year later the movie
super intelligence saw melissa mccarthy
being directed by her husband ben falcom
pretty normal since they love
collaborating together her partner on
screen however was bobby cannavale which
mccarthy was not complaining about if
the kiss needed another take
can we get that kiss again i'm like sure
thing honey the actors have had to kiss
a few times for work now and it seems
like by the time mccarthy got to mac on
canavale she was really feeling it i
mean i know that i love bobby
looking at all these relationships that
have blossomed from on-screen romances
shows just how powerful these working
connections can be what's not so great
is switching from having great kisses to
having not so fun ones after breaking up